so
um mirrorland came out was dope um your
guys is like official
debut album uh the spillage village
project was real special
um now we got the wale single i'm
assuming that uh well first of all how
close are you guys
done um with this album and and like
like you know how many songs are we
looking at
we're pretty close we're close we're not
100 finished but we're pretty close and
um
i say give or take like maybe like round
12 or something
okay that's a nice one that's a nice
number yeah and and then you know
obviously you got one lay on the project
yeah young thug on the last project
which had to be
you know um is there going to be any
dreamville brethren on this album
it's in the words like we just got a
whole lot of records we're still
polishing that's something
we see we'll see who fits where we try
to get the meat of the project
done which is definitely done you know
something like the the bulk of the bulk
of the idea is done the concept
is beautiful i'm really excited for it
right right right yeah we gotta figure
out where everybody is gonna go like
casting wise
who was um first to sign with dreamville
was it
and i'm i don't call him jid because i
called him jade in person once
and he was like i don't know you like
that you got to call me
but like was it you guys are was a jid
first we saw around the same time
actually
okay uh when uh when when cole
cole met us in person
at the uh absolute tour is it the new
york day
and uh we we actually were opening for
for seoul and jill at the time was um
he was my roommate so i ain't gonna you
know say we first got the offer from
episode
to go on tour he's my roommate that's
like my boy my brother
we made hello songs together i ain't
gonna do just earth gang going to
without him and just leave him there so
he was like hey bro
come on twitter with us he he so he we
we split our set with him
just on something like bruh just on some
homie [ __ ] on some brother [ __ ] bro we
not gonna
we need things to go you know saying we
all know without even like clearing it
with absolutely look we got the homie
coming in
nobody that's [ __ ] put up with him
he's like now bro we're gonna split this
[ __ ] like
we're gonna get this shine you don't get
to shine you did and uh
when cole met us he was like that was
cool man who's the other dude show he's
like that's already just so he's like
man all y'all coming in so
we all would literally pile up in the
car together because i said he was
roommates
so we get up in the car together and
travel to north carolina together and we
just all spent time with calling he was
like man so what's your situation
looking like and then he was like we
ain't got now so he just signed us all
around the same time
he it just so happened we jit had had
never stole it ready almost as soon as
he got signed so wow so he was ready
yeah he put that out and then we put out
the eps and then our album
subsequently yo it's crazy because
like i feel like cole's been so careful
about who he brings on to the team and
there's so much artistic integrity on
that roster
and you know i feel like coke could sign
anybody like he could probably at this
point you know he'd literally go out and
probably
sign you know any of the bubbling up and
coming rappers like
but i feel like he he cares so much
about the
the brand of dreamville and like just
the integrity of the music that comes
out of that you know what i'm saying
like he won't make
you want to make foreign cars man he's
going to make exciting right
here because over here right and like
some some exotics you wouldn't like you
know that
yeah no that's cranking out no forest
right right right